all right he is the former national
security adviser under President Trump
an author of the new book I'm sure
you've heard about it the room where it
happened a White House memoir john
bolton from washington DC ambassador
thank you for being here are there and I
know you have a big book out I'm gonna
start with something you said in it
you're talking about the virus you said
Trump didn't want to hear warnings about
the virus because you didn't want to
hear bad things about President Xi of
China that could affect the fantastic
trade deal he was working on are you
saying he botched the coronavirus
response because he was protecting China
well I think it's that's very
substantially the case I think in the
critical early months January February
maybe even before that there was an
empty chair in the Oval Office the
experts around our government on the NSC
staff and the Centers for Disease
Control and elsewhere were we're raising
the red flag President did not want to
be bothered with it he didn't want to
hear about the cover-up the outright
deception that China was engaged in in
terms of the extent and the nature of
the virus and he particularly didn't
want to hear anything that could
foreshadow trouble for the American
economy because of the disease that
might upset his path to re-election so
there's a long list that I won't repeat
them all but people can find it in
online and in newspapers of statements
Trump made senior officials made saying
the virus is not a threat we've got it
under control there won't be any impact
and and that cost us a lot of time and
earlier steps could well have mitigated
the effect of the disease substantially
okay staying with China for a minute
here Twitter last week purged 174
thousand accounts fake accounts from the
Chinese government and of course we know
from the last election and what all our
intelligence agencies told us that
Russia was playing mischief not only
with social media but also trying to
directly hack into our election system
what did you as National Security
Advisor do to protect us from happening
from this happening again well first let
me say I think it's
very clear that Russia and perhaps
others did interfere in the 2016
election I said before I joined the
White House I considered that to be an
act of war against the Constitution and
I feel even more strongly today about it
than I did then Russia has been joined
in the past couple years by China Iran
North Korea probably others vice
president pence gave an important speech
that China's effort which focuses not
simply on interfering in the elections
although that's obviously very
disturbing but on broader efforts to
affect the American public opinion what
we found in in looking at our possible
responses was that the u.s. government
was bound up by a series of procedural
rules I won't get into the details that
made it very hard for the United States
to conduct offensive cyber operations my
view and I think view widely shared the
government was that the best defense
against Russian attacks or Chinese
attacks or anybody's attacks was to have
our own offensive capability so that we
could impose costs on those who tried to
interfere with us to the point where we
could create structures of deterrence so
that in Moscow and Beijing they would
say it costs us too much to interfere in
American elections we're going to back
off that battle goes on let there be no
mistake I think their efforts to
interfere even now in the election and I
think really what our adversaries want
to do is disrupt America's institution
so mistrust among the American people
but we focus on are they backing Trump
are they backing somebody else it's
really the larger attack on our entire
political system I think we should be
looking at
you